foreign
morality Patrol killed 22 year old
masaminee while in custody for improper
veiling in September 2022
sparking months of anti-riching protests
and the first women-led movement of its
kind the regime brutally suppressed
dissidents killing roughly 500 including
children
and arresting tens of thousands
protests in Iran may have subsided in
recent months
but the mass Avenue protest movement
still poses the greatest threat to the
Iranian regime in its 44-year history
this is due in part to the fact that
protest participation spans
socioeconomic ethnic and religious lines
and called for significant political
changes including the overthrow of the
regime
recent demonstrations resulted in the
highest number of deaths among security
personnel and reportedly created
fractures within the regime
Iranian leaders have not granted
protesters concessions
this coupled with Iran's deteriorating
economic conditions will further
exacerbate anti-regime sentiments
in other words this movement will
continue to haunt the regime despite the
decline of civil unrest
how do you think the women of Iran will
spark change in the Islamic Republic let
us know in our comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like for our
Scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like And subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI